welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's keynote webinar
modernizing drug development through
digital transformation in
non-traditional models presented by dr.
chiffon Baran head of emerging
technologies le s at Novartis my name is
Stephan Shankar and I will be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
webinars series presented by web roots
lab roots is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtues events and
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
questions box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
spawned to your questions following the
presentation if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the ask a questions box
to let us know that you're experiencing
a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credit tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window following the
process to obtain your credits now
without further ado please join me in
welcoming dr. Barron I will now turn
over the presentation to him so welcome
everybody and thank you for joining us
today first I would like to thank lab
roots for giving me an opportunity to
talk about digitization as well as
non-traditional models which are really
engaged in the conversations these days
so a typical disclaimer and any view
starts or opinion so you're going to
hear today our mind and my own and not
affiliated with my employer or any
associations I'm part of so I think many
of us are aware that the medicine
development journey is a long journey
it can take anywhere from 10 to 15 years
it's an expensive journey can take over
two billion dollars
and there are several reasons for that
so one is the efficacy so challenges
with translations from preclinical to
clinical and in that efficacy area the
oncology plays the biggest role so also
reproducibility is another challenge for
us so here you see a graph and studies
by various organizations demonstrating
that and as the cost of medicine
development and bringing those medicines
to patients has increased over several
years the number of medicines they were
actually providing to patients has not
so as you can see there is definitely
opportunities where we could look for
efficiencies and increasing the number
of medicines that we could bring to
patients and I hope that the models they
were going to talk about today and the
digital technologies that we're going to
discuss are going to demonstrate their
potential of how they could impact this
journey so there's a lot of different
emerging technologies you know that you
sure you have heard of machine learning
Big Data artificial intelligence lab on
a chip and various non traditional
models so today we're going to take two
paths which I will demonstrate to you
and also discuss their potential or
helping us deliver medicines to patients
faster the first one we're going to talk
about non-traditional models and then
the second one we're going to talk about
digitization and big data so let's start
off with an organ on a chip so what is
organ on a chip organ on a chip also
called micro physiological systems is a
microfluidic device capable of emulating
human or any other animal species
biology in vitro at the smallest
biologically acceptable scale defined by
purpose
so there's various industries they have
engaged with these platforms these
technologies but today we're going to
concentrate on the pharmaceutical
industry so here you see several
examples of these technologies so if we
start from clockwise you can see a blind
brain barrier technology by Vanderbilt
University Harvard has also introduced
cardiac muscle we have also a kidney by
Norris Draper has also introduced female
reproductive tract at the Washington
University a vascular tumor models if
you switch to the left side you can see
Columbia has introduced a skin epidermis
model Washington University vasculature
liver by University of Pittsburgh and
long but emulate again these are not all
inclusive technologies is just some of
the examples and they're currently
available to us so what's the purpose
behind these platforms what's to emulate
architecture cell to cell cell to matrix
homeostasis as well signaling including
biochemical as well as mechanical and
when we're talking about disease models
looking at the emergence of the disease
all the way through the progression of
the disease and so over last couple
decades has been demonstrated that the
basic models the 2d cultures have
obviously had a huge impact on
development of medicines but as the
complexity increases the recuperation of
those environments can help us identify
other functionalities as well as
biomarkers and and just really set up
and more emulating micro environment
that we can learn from so here's an
example of a lung on a chip so as you
can see you have epithelium on one side
in a membrane in the middle and as you
can see on the left-hand side of the
image under a if where you see the
vacuum if you introduced the vacuum it
allows you to collapse and expand that
membrane which is for example for us
like we will
be exhaling and inhaling and on the
right-hand side you can see that example
what that lung in the chip technology
looks like so it's the size of a USB
Drive and so here is just one of the
examples of characterizing this
technology so here we compare organ on a
chip with a mouse lung and so when we
introduce interleukin 2 it increases the
permeability and you can see that has
been demonstrated on the lung-on-a-chip
and similar to how long so then also
when we combine that with an inch one
again this is a black border you can see
on the right hand side the lung on the
chip technology has demonstrated that
permeability drops off decreases and
same with that whole lung so when we
talk about organ and chip technologies
we can categorize them into three
different types or categories we have
the single organ which we just learned
about the lung and a chip then you can
have multi organ technologies where you
pull together different organ so here on
the bottom you can see an example of a
digestive system including gut and liver
and for example brain so you can emulate
ingestion of a medicine and how it
metabolizes within that system and on
the right hand side you can see the
actual system by draper so then we also
have body on the chip so this is a
program that was initially started with
NIH where there's a proposal sent out to
develop a body on a chip and the
requirement for that was to have a
minimum of ten organs on that chip and
as you can see but UCF and a Cornell and
there was a chip that developed that has
all of those different organs that are
interacting within that technology so
looking at you know where these
technologies can help us so this
technology can address
some of that critical needs that we have
for example limitation or conventional
systems so we talked about you know 2d
systems versus more complex 3d systems
including flows within them
for example screening and toxicity
testing immune Janissa T modelling or
aadmi so looking at absorption
distribution metabolism and excretion of
the compounds or medicines pk/pd
modeling and analysis looking at
efficacy testing by providing various
disease models and also understanding
the mechanics of the disease models and
also looking at for example rare
diseases where some of those models in
vivo for example might not exist and
again this is not an all-inclusive list
these are just some of the examples one
of the questions that often comes up
with these technologies is can organ on
a chip replace in vivo models that we
utilize and there's certainly a
potential for that but in these early
stages were still far away from that but
these systems can add to the information
that were obtaining from these disease
models from the in vivo models and help
us with decision making processes so
we're through this journey of Medicine
development candies technologies help us
the organ and chip technologies so they
can potentially assist us with selecting
targets and leads prioritizing our drug
candidates as you could see on that
initial slides you know there's
thousands of compounds that we start off
with and then also with the decision
making process again at these early
stages we still have to really define
the context of use for these
technologies and as we move forward we
really need to characterize validate
these technologies as well and so I
showed you a couple examples of organ
and a chip and here is another example
and really the point of this image is to
show you that some of these technologies
are extremely complex so for example the
throughput here is going to be lower
than with some of the other technologies
available to us but again this is where
we end these early stages really have to
identify the context of use for these
technologies so now we're going to
switch gears a little bit and talk about
in vivo models so the one health concept
is not a new one has been around for a
while and this is the concept that
allows us to learn from comparative
models so from animals people and
they're pulling the environment into
that but recently this concept is really
receiving a lot of attention and gaining
ground within our industry and under the
one health we have competitive medicine
so here we're concentrating again on
learning from animals and people as we
develop drugs and medicines for people
but also for our four-legged friends
and again this is not a novel concept
rudolf virchow and 1800 has introduced
this concept that we can learn from
animals and people together and pulling
the information allows us to develop
various medicines so today we're going
to talk and concentrate on comparative
oncology so like I mentioned from
efficacy perspective oncology is where
we have most of the challenges as we
move our medicines forward so here
there's even a PBS piece on comparative
oncology and we'll highly recommend if
you have time to check it out but again
this is one of this concept that's now
allowing us to look at our four-legged
friends and the medicines are being
developed for them and learn from them
and translate that information into
clinics and even doing that together
allowing us to do that even more
efficiently so here's just an example of
the incidence of cancers that happens in
people so it's about a little bit over
400 per hundred thousand patients per
year mortality rate is a little bit over
150 but when you look at the animals
specifically dogs the incidence rate is
between 400 to 800 and also for benign
tumors it's about 900 but the leading
cause of death for canines over 10 years
is cancer so there's definitely a lot of
opportunities for us to engage both
sides this chart as you can see on the
left-hand side there's various tumors
listed there you have glioma
osteosarcoma and melanoma and these are
common tumors that happen in dogs but
I'm sure you can also now think that
these are common tumors that happen in
people so obviously we have used in vivo
models that they have a huge impact and
allow us to bring medicines to patients
but there are some challenges with this
models there's lack of key micro
environment components there there is
short cancer development timeline so a
rodent is about two years where
obviously we live you know now to what
it's about 80 years there is a
homogeneous environment there where in
people it's more heterogeneous and
there's also increased therapy tolerance
so when we provide that compounds to
rodents they are not necessarily
impactful or highly more efficient than
for example in people and also the
cancer models are induced where if
you're looking at our four-legged
friends and those are naturally
occurring cancers just like they do in
people so here's just some examples of
where these cancer models that cure or
cancers that cure and Pat's a mirror
really what happens in people and again
today I'm not going to dive into in
depth into these various aspects because
we have speakers throughout today and
tomorrow
they're going to be diving into these
more in depth and I would highly
encourage you to participate and join
those sessions so here on top you see a
graph that really shows milestones in
canine oncology and with the times it
really matches the advancements that we
have also seen in people and on the
bottom you have some of the medicines
that have been developed for people
where animals have played a significant
role in helping understanding us
understanding this medicines and
defining them as we bring it forward
so where can these animal models these
companion animal studies for example
help us in drug development and again
obviously as we're developing them for
our pets here we can align with our
preclinical studies and more even in
phase one and Phase two studies so they
can assist us with understanding the
efficacy that's more translatable
pharmacology identifying biomarkers for
example and of course there's some
various that we're going to have to
address just like with any novel model
and again a dog is not a novel model but
it has now been used as preclinical
studies in development with companion
animals so this is where I see that as a
non-traditional model but there are
certainly some challenges you know how
do you recruit patients four-legged
patients in this case to these studies
um and but now there are some
significant initiatives and impacting an
allowance to help that recently NIH has
sponsored a grant we're pulling various
veterinary schools and building this
database I'm also keeping this patients
on our studies and demonstrating their
impact designing the studies to match
our clinical studies so those are just
some of the examples which we'll have to
dive in more and
and address and again this is going to
be presented in one of the presentations
by Amy later on today so now let's
switch gears and talk about digitization
so here's an example of over 80
companies that are investing in
developing digital hospitals one of them
is at University of Pennsylvania and so
some of the examples were robots bring
the food to patients from a patient
coming into the hospital
and kind of like at the fast-food
restaurant where you enter your
information what you want to order so
the patient can come in and do that it
allows for different wearables that the
patient can have as the patient is in a
hospital and something happens you know
initially would have to page a physician
to come and assist that patient and a
physician could be on the other end of
the hospital so time obviously of an
essence so one of the examples with this
technologies then when something happens
to the patient that hospital receives
the signal from their patient and allows
you to identify the closest physician
that could assist that patient and again
this is just one of many examples where
these technologies are being developed
on the clinical sites and on a
healthcare side one of the other
challenges is you know when we go see a
for example dermatologist or a regular
doctor or oncologist and all the
information you know how do you get
access to it so it's kind of
discombobulated so now it's being pulled
together so again as an example
University of Pennsylvania Hospital
they're they're working where they have
a system that each doctor from different
background can access all patients
information which makes it again easier
for them to and more efficient to make
the decisions or how to move forward and
help that patient so when we look at the
preclinical environment and so there are
several phases that we need to consider
the first one is data gathering
here a few examples that you have is a
digital vive area which collect
information from the animals 24/7 you
have a smart glass hololens which allows
us to collect information but it also is
important that the animals almost
digitized so using a microchip
subcutaneous microchip which allows us
to track the animal but also potentially
provide the temperature of the animal
and other information so these are just
a few examples and today we're going to
touch out more on the digital vivarium
and also in the smart glasses but as
this information is being collected
obviously a different companies you have
different sites many companies are
global but then even in a
pre-competitive space how can we learn
from this information pull this
information together so addressing the
aspect of pulling and structuring the
data so then we can also analyze the
data using a competitive aspect I'm an
AI for example and then this data really
has to be easily accessible to us and
and also we should be able to visualize
it very rapidly and so we can also make
decisions faster and not search for that
information so like I mentioned were
going to talk about digital vivarium
first and so here are several companies
that provide us technologies so again
these are technologies where we can
monitor animals 24/7 and all of these
are scalable so one example is a smart
housing so on the left hand side you see
Iraq and the caging system or the cage
is on the right so this system has
cameras so allows you to monitor animals
24/7 through the cameras and collect
things like activity respiratory rate
and also disk aging have individual
lighting so one of the challenges for us
is are the animals at the bottom of the
racks are receiving the same light that
the animals on top and you know
potentially that might be impact for how
the medicines are being metabolized so
here each cage
has the same lighting also you can plate
place running wheels in these systems
and monitor the engagement of the
animals with the systems and the speed
so for example when you're looking at
aging studies you know as the animals
interacting with the running wheel
versus the ones that are not they're in
better shape as their activity increases
the physiological biomarkers are
different just one of the examples where
this could be potentially use so how
does this platform work so you collect
information at the cage level it's
kicked into the crowd to the cloud where
again it's being structured and analyzed
and then it's being kicked back into the
scientists access so here the scientists
have real-time access to the data as the
study is progressing versus waiting for
it so potentially would allow you to
make those decisions or should we move
forward with the study or not and here's
just the interface so you can see the
novel digital biomarkers so again like
the respiratory rate the activity level
of the animals but also allows you to
see the traditional aspects are being
collected so for example changing cages
looking at the animals making clinical
assessments weighing the animals all the
information as combined in just one spot
so again it's very efficient and in it's
in real-time so this is you know has an
impact obviously on the scientist as an
impact and an operational side but also
has an impact on animal well-being as
well so here's another example of a
digital housing this is by actual
analytics so here you have a rack on the
left hand side and as you have two rows
one of the rows you remove that cages
and you can place the camera system the
technology in there to monitor the cage
next door this is a video based as well
as RFID based system initially this
technology was developed several years
for behavioral observations but now as
we're engaging with
technologies there is a lot of potential
in different aspects of medicine
development preclinically where these
technologies could be utilized so here's
just an example of a few manuscripts
they have been recently published with
these technologies and again there's
only a few right now and when you
compare to some of the other
technologies that we have been working
with for a long time but again just like
with the organ on a chip we really need
to characterize these technologies we
need to validate these technologies and
even more importantly identify the
contexts of use for these technologies
so the next data gathering instrument
that we're going to talk about is the
hololens so there's various smart
glasses out there and so the hololens
when you put it on it allows you to see
the environment around you but it also
allows you to for example pull up an
Excel spreadsheet with the animals
information or your patients information
um and you can also a dictate your
findings to that to that system so you
know how this technology can help us so
here's an example of an assessment of
our animals and again I know these are
going to vary from institution to
institution but here's this example that
has 15 steps and we when we engage with
the hololens one i don't have to write
down information i can just dictate the
information if the animal for example is
being recognized by the hololens I don't
have to reach and check each animal
individually for example for a tail
marker but the technology allows me to
tells me which animal I'm looking at so
again this is going to decrease the
number of steps that are required for
this assessment and it's also going to
expedite some of these process of some
of these steps within this process so
here's another example where this
technology could have impact so
now for example we're looking at the
animals so the animal technician takes a
look at the animal and then most of the
cases they can make the decision on how
to proceed but if they can't they reach
out to a veterinary technician the
veterinary technician runs over looks at
the animal and in most cases they're
able to make the decision but if they're
not now they have to reach out to the
veterinarian
now the veterinarian trucks over there
looks at the animal and in most cases we
can make the decision there but
potentially we need to reach out to the
scientist so now you have four people
that need it to be engaged in this in
this decision process very often um the
facilities are in different spaces
different locations so you have to go
between the facilities if you're lucky
maybe it's in the same facility but now
you also had four people they enter the
facility so there is an increased risk
of contamination but also the amount of
time that's being spent doing that and
also the delay now from looking at the
animal and how we're going to engage
with the animal is pretty significant so
using the hololens the technician can
look at the animal with the hololens and
live share the image in the video of the
animal and reach out to a veterinarian
very technician and if necessary as
scientists live and make the decision
right there and there what to do and how
to proceed and if you cannot for example
reach the veterinarian right away you
can take the image or the video so then
a veterinarian again can look at the
animal at his or her desk and again this
is not going to work for all of our
cases but it certainly can for for many
of them so here's another technology and
this is something that you can actually
put around a collar around your pet pets
neck and it collects various activity
level as well as physiological markers
and again this is a technology that I'm
not aware of that's being used within
our industry however
this is something that I requested as a
Christmas gift for myself and my kids
and my wife bought that for for me so we
placed that on porkchop who is one of
our pets one of our many pads and can I
wanted to check it out how does this
work so again you have the color and you
have the base station which connects to
that to that color so here this
technology can monitor the activity
level of porkchop
and also even look at our delaying on
the left side on the right side so for
example after surgery is the animal
still favoring one side or the other you
know assessing pain for example you know
these are some of the possibilities also
you can look at the pulse and the
respiratory rate so for example if the
animal is painful maybe that will
coincide with it but again you know can
we imagine utilizing this in our for
example safety studies with with dogs
we're currently you know we try to
monitor them as much as we can but here
we have access to real to information in
real time and you can monitor obviously
24/7 or four to three days if you need
to so again this is one of those
technologies that's not currently
utilizing in our industry but is a huge
potential and again it's not going to
address all of our areas all of our
challenges but can certainly have an
impact there this is an article that
recently you know I just pulled up on
one health addressing obesity in people
and it paths and I must say that when we
put the collar on porkchop one of the
things that we started to monitor is his
activity level and we almost made it not
almost but we did we made it to the game
so I have two sons and so there's a
competition who can make the make
porkchop run more steps in a day and to
make the long story short over the last
month
a porkchop has lost some significant
weight because of that and he certainly
could use that as well as ourselves so
now we're going to switch gears and
about data big data so from all of these
models that we talked about the in vitro
model the in vivo model digitizing some
of our processes and all comes with
enormous amount of data so how do we
address it how do we work with it so one
of the examples you know in their
clinical let's say phase 2 study an
oncologist is made aware of some aspect
that happened to the to the patient or
side effect so they want to take a look
at you know what happened in our in vivo
in the preclinical studies so they
typically reach out to a person as
access to that information or guide and
where to find information then that
information is being gathered and then
presented to that to that clinician but
if this event happens on the weekends
now we have to wait until Monday
potentially the person might be away on
vacation so now we're another week out
and very gravely to say spend two to
three weeks so having that information
our fingertips where I can look at the
medicine that we're utilizing in
patients and look at you know what
happened preclinically would be enormous
ly helpful so the volume of data is just
amazing from all of the studies that we
perform and have performed in the past
and accessing the data you know here are
a couple studies or a few studies but
various organizations that you know we
spend nearly 25 percent of time looking
for data almost 40 percent access for
searching and recreating that content so
as an example for presentations a
presentation you know that I'm giving
today but I have content over the last
two or three years for it so now
searching and going back for that and
50% need to search five or more sources
for that and again when you look at the
animal technician for example versus
scientists these times are going to vary
but with all of the public
they're coming out recently just imagine
that amount you know how do you access
even for PubMed for example so as the
data volume increases our knowledge or
clinical utility is pretty low there's
this enormous gap right so how do we
decrease that gap with all of the data
so we're actually able to utilize it
together so what we really want is
everybody and again different levels
here but they would have access to the
information from the starting point of
looking at the compound or the medicine
all the way through our clinical trials
so you know we talked about a couple
technologies here and so you know how
does this should work so pulling the
information into the cloud then being
able to analyze the information and
structure that data so then everybody
can can access it and again this is very
simplified process and this is where I
would encourage you to participate in
the sessions that are going to be
happening later on today and tomorrow
during these virtual events where
there's going to be colleagues are going
to be addressing each part of this
pathway of this journey and talking
about the challenges as well as the
solutions to those challenges so the way
I would envision that would love to have
and I'm sure there's a lot of other
colleagues that we like that as well
it's having a dashboard and again this
is just a mock-up dashboard but I can
look at all of our sites and look at all
of the in vivo studies that are being
performed there and see you know at what
stage they are you know the animals
well-being as well so then we can
address it but also later on collect
that data and learn from it so one of
the things we talked about is the
hololens where an animal technician can
access the veterinary technician the
veterinarian a scientist or in real-time
but just imagine that now all of this
data is being
collected so how was the animal treated
what was the outcome so over next year
or two when the data is pulled together
when the animal technician has that
smart glasses on and pulls up the
clinical signs that he or she is
observing and now the system can let
them know that in 80% of the cases this
is what was the next step and this was
the outcome of it so potentially now
they don't have to engage with everybody
else than aligned but help them make the
decision right there and then you know
also looking at you know how many active
cases do we have how many studies are we
running again from the operational
perspective as well as from the
scientists perspective and also looking
from the animal will being perspective
also you know what are they approved CRS
that we're working with so if the
scientists wants to do a specific study
they can very rapidly check again if you
could look at this onus on his phone
pull this information up within seconds
and see hey there's a CRO within a few
miles from us that we can engage with or
that CRO that I really need is you know
on the other side of the o of the ocean
you know how am I going to address that
but again it's expediting the process of
decision making and as with any
technology there is this hype about the
technology so Gartner every year puts up
at this hype cycle diagram where again
you know when people start talking about
AI everybody gets all excited about it
and we should all engage with the
technology because it's going to do
wonders for us with the same thing with
digitization and very rapidly we learned
that our expectations are just not met
but this technology's so then we proceed
with that and the investment slows down
and the engagement slows down and then
slowly over time we end up engaging with
more specific ones or kind of sub
categories of those technologies as we
move forward and identify the yes that
can really impact our processes so how
can we kind of shorten this dis aspect
kind of tighten disk
so one is really having realistic
expectations but also understanding that
capabilities true capabilities of these
technologies and just like with any
novel technologies any novel models
there's things gonna have to be
characterized and worked out as we move
forward so very often when the
technology is presented to us we think
this is fantastic let's start utilizing
and then we try to find you know how can
we utilize it where can we kind of force
this technology into our processes so
excuse me so taking a step back and
identifying some of the challenges
identifying the problems that we have
and then looking at the chronology and
how can the technology address the
specific problems so this is where we
talk about the context of use for these
technologies also as we look at this you
know to expedite this process of
characterization validation it really
has to be a collaborative process so one
example you know a technology provider
develops the technology they believe
this is fantastic everybody should be
buying it but when the end-user for
example for industry looks at it you so
you know no it still needs this and this
and this to help us address our problem
so having the conversations at the
earlier stages is really helpful and it
benefits the the end user as well as the
technology providers and of course this
can have impact on the regulatory aspect
as well right we want to make the
process of getting medicines to patients
more efficient and more of this
medicines to to our patients so having
early conversations with organizations
like FDA and as well as even you know
all over the world with regulatory
agencies at the early stages is really
important and then again collaboration
so here you have an example of the IQ
consortium so that Q consortium has
organ on a chip affiliate now which is
developing for example manuscripts which
going to be published and addressing
what would be their aspects of the
technologies like organ and chip they
would really help us answer some of
their challenges or questions that we
have the group also has a digital
vivarium group form with risk companies
where we're looking from the
pre-competitive in a pre-competitive
space on you know how to potentially
engage with those technologies and what
questions or answers that could provide
so today we talked about two paths one
we talked about non-traditional models
and then we also looked at the data and
the digitization and again I hope that
it presented some of the potential for
all these technologies but I believed an
engagement here and taking those two
paths is going to has the potential to
help us make medicine get medicines to
patients more efficiently so here's my
contact information and if you have any
questions please feel free to reach out
to me and I'll be more than happy to
chat with you offline as well so with
that said again I would like to thank
thank lab roots for giving me
opportunity to present this topic and
now we're going to pass it on to my
moderator
Thank You dr. Baron for that informative
presentation we'll now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have
any questions you'd like to ask please
do so now simply click on the ask the
questions box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box let's get started with
our first question
how is permeability of lung conscious
constructs tested was ter used or a
different method so thank you so much
for that question and to be that's
something that I can forward you that
paper which I pulled from there but
unfortunately that's not so just to talk
about the organ on a chip and I don't
work with those technologies and more
from a strategic perspective that's
where I'm involved so I'll definitely
reach out to you afterwards and share
with you the manuscript that addressed
the specific organ on the chip all right
our next question what are the levels
one two three or fours as is shown on a
global perspective as level one good or
bad and NORs level four good or bad and
what constitutes levels so that's a
fantastic question and so there again
this is kind of a mock version of the
platform and this is something that you
know you can develop so we don't it
doesn't specify specifically what it is
we have not identified what those are
but that's the way I would envision that
we would do that all right our next
question can you speak a little bit
about the current innovation available
for digitizing mice with RFID technology
now definitely so there are several
technologies available to us and you
know some with one of the again looking
at characterizing and you know where did
the kannada is going to be used so there
are companies like so mark UID that
present those technologies and others
but really again finding out how the
technology is going to address your
questions your challenges is really
important and also is a high frequency
low frequency how are you going to end
up
reading and collecting that information
so one of the things to again consider
that if you're coming to the room and
you want to scan all of the animals
within that room is going to be
different frequency for example if I go
in and look at the cage level and also
from their beginning you know how you're
going to implement it so the way I would
in envision that you could implement
this is at when we bring the animals
from the beginning that we purchase the
animals that the animals are for example
chipped or mark with other technologies
that then allows us to track the animals
during the travel time when they come to
a facility and one of the challenges
with reproducibility is that potentially
the information can be miss misaligned
with different animals so here having
for example one ID number that goes
along with the animal through its
lifetime and being meta tagged with
different numbers there for example
scientists use would allow us to
potentially address one of those those
aspects alright our next question as you
mentioned the concept of one health is
not a new one why is there been such a
delay in lack of embracing this concept
by pharmaceutical industries so again
it's a thank you for that question and
that's questions that I have been asking
for a for a while now and there are
various challenges with that I think the
biggest one was being able to develop a
data bank where we can understand the
frequency of the cancers that occur the
numbers W of animals that we would have
you know we could have access to and so
this way allows us to align the
development or design of those
preclinical studies with the clinical
studies and again later on today we're
going to hear from from Amy at n IC
addressing that question and engagement
has been there there's various studies
have demonstrated that that can actually
help us getting paid drug to patients
more efficiently but it's definitely
still
there's some barriers that we have to
overcome for it and again these within
last five to six years the engagement
has they has significant and the
investment and those areas has grown so
I'm definitely looking forward to seeing
in the next five to ten years how we can
collaborate with comparative medicine
and oncology alright and our final
question
AI seems to have disrupted every aspect
of most industries has AI been
implemented within the non clinical side
of drug development is bio
pharmaceutical industry ready for this
so thank you so much for this question
as well and obviously as a
pharmaceutical industry we have invested
in AI on the clinical side and has an
impact there and their return on
investment is not as prompt as fast as
we would like and on a preclinical side
I think the impact understanding and
we're a little bit slower to adopt that
technology and on one side I think
that's not a bad thing because allows us
to learn from our clinical colleagues
and other industries but now I think
it's the right time to engage with that
technology and again looking at the
context of use for their technology so
again we don't have to invest in every
piece or throughout the path of
preclinical but there's definitely has
some impact one of the technology where
AI has been used is for pathology so for
image analysis for his esta logical
slides for example has demonstrated
impact they're also looking at
configurations and interaction of
molecules they're also 3d as well as
were virtual reality and computational
technologies have made significant
progress alright and we did have a few
more questions come in so we're going to
get to these right now how does this
information progress with all concerns
and issues with using a mouse model and
trying to translate the information
collected being applied to human
medicine
so again the models that we have
currently have definitely helped us
significantly with medicine development
I think that with the different models
for example like comparative oncology
are going to help us to learn more about
the diseases and medicines that can help
us address those diseases or impact
those diseases but I think the biggest
the question that we really have to
address is how do we pull the data
together and then how do we utilize that
data because again the data is
continuously being collected but we're
not really engaging with the data we
still have the knowledge gap there so
this is one of the bigger questions from
my perspective is how do we structure
the data how do we pull the data
together so that we can access it
analyze it and then see is it going to
impact this medicine journey of getting
the medicines to patients alright and
another question here your graphic
relating finding and recreating data and
results in a very common reality well
digital Vibram technologies make big
data larger with endless data points or
make big bit excuse me or make big data
more focused and more manageable so
again it's it's everything comes down to
a to two data and the information that
we're collecting and the question comes
up all the time now we have all of this
data you know can we really use it is it
going to really impact you know how we
make our decisions and again I think
identifying specific challenges and
problems that we have so one example is
the respiratory rate so typically on
respiratory studies we end up monitoring
the weight of the animals and clinically
observed the animal assess as we're
looking at efficacy or the respiratory
disease models so but when I go into a
physician's office they look at my
respiratory rate they look at my
activity level so here for example with
the respiratory rate ability and looking
at the activity
and it's more clinically aligned and
it's more clinically relevant is it
translational and I think there's a
potential for it but this is one of the
things that we have to characterize and
invalidate so I think that we're in such
early stages in a preclinical arena with
implementing all these technologies that
we need to really address how is that
data are going to be pulled together and
process and that really has to be
addressed because initially when we jump
into you know I mentioned various
technologies that were pulling together
so there's still descanse eped that you
know let's look at this one technology
and kind of almost isolate it you know
and how is it gonna work I wasn't gonna
impact but we have to right off the bat
start thinking if we look at this
technology in this technology you know
how is the data going to be structure
how is it going to interface with other
technologies so I think that's one of
the big questions and if we can do that
and address the challenge I think there
were going to be able to demonstrate the
impact of the data that we're collecting
on this process all right so that does
conclude all of our questions for the
day I would like to thank once again dr.
Barron for this presentation I'd also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I would want to let
everyone know that this webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
May 14 2019 that's all for now thank you
for joining us and see you next time
you